After we completely factored, here's what we end up with. Looking at the
denominator, x can equal 0, 2, or 1. So I'll write those values in this box to
tell us about the domain. X can equal 0, 1, or 2. Great, that takes care of
half the problem. Now onto the range. Let's look at our horizontal asymptote.
If there is one at all. First though, I need to multiply out what's in the
denominator and the numerator. So we have a form that we can use for long
division. In the numerator I'll have x cubed minus x. And in the denominator,
we have 2x to the 4th minus 6 x cubed plus 4x squared. Great. Now we can
divide. Setting up our long division problem. I need to see how many times 2x
to the 4th goes into x cubed. Well, that's just 0 times. I could carry on with
my long division. But I know already that we're going to have a horizontal
asymptote at. That y equals 0. Now the question is is this an asymptote that
the function crosses or not. To find out let's plug in 0 for y in our function.
I know that this equation will be satisfied if the numerator is just equal to
0. As long as the denominator is not undefined. At whatever value of x we need
to do this. So let's just set x times x squared minus 1 equal to 0. Two of
these factors x and x minus 1. Are also in the denominator, so I'm going to
cross them out. But we still one left over, x plus 1. This means that x equals
negative 1, the graph of our function crosses through the horizontal asymptote.
Since the horizontal asymptote, then, is not restricting our range, the range
is just all the real numbers. So we can write a none in this box. Awesome, that
was a super complicated quiz, so if you got through it, great job.